dutzende aktivisten haben am samstag am
tagebau garzweiler die polizeikette
durchbrochen und sind in die
tagebaugrube gelangt die polizei
appellierte an die demonstranten
friedlich zu bleiben und versuchte die
klimaschützer von der abbruchkante
fernzuhalten der sprecher der polizei
aachen andreas müller
also wir haben hier über 600
quadratkilometer einsatz fläche zu
betreuen und über und 90 kilometer
abbruchkante das heißt unser
einsatzkonzept war gar nicht darauf
ausgelegt dieses gelände hier zu jeder
zeit an jedem ort 100% abzusichern dafür
würde auch die ganze polizei nrw es
nicht ausreichen wir haben schwerpunkte
gesetzt
und natürlich bleiben da irgendwo lücken
und da muss man auch damit rechnen dass
bei solchen aktionen das die aktivisten
ebene befinden zum anderen muss man
sagen es ist nicht überall friedlich
zugegangen
da wo polizeiketten standen sind diese
teilweise auch gewaltsam gesprochen
worden
tausende menschen waren nach angaben der
bewegung ende gelände zum tagebau
garzweiler gekommen um ihrer forderung
nach einem sofortigen kohleausstieg
nachdruck zu verleihen
die klimaschützer kritisierten
einschränkungen durch die polizei
sprecherin von ende gelände kathrin
henneberger
die polizei versucht von mal zu mal uns
immer mehr steine in den weg zu legen
und dieses mal mussten wir sehr hart
kämpfen für ein camp das haben wir dann
bekommen per gerichtsentscheid die
umweltschützer haben auch die schienen
zum kohlekraftwerk neurath blockiert so
dass das kraftwerk von der kohle zuvor
abgeschnitten war sowie die hambachbahn
besetzt es kam zum einsatz von
pfefferspray und festnahm
mehrere personen wurden verletzt die
bundesregierung will ende september
klären wie sie die klimaschutzziele 2030
erreichen kann
die einen drastischen abbau der
treibhausgase mission vorsehen
bisher ist der ausstieg aus der
braunkohleverstromung nach den
empfehlungen der pole kommission bis
2038 geplant